[Music]
this book is already changing my life
thank you and IMS the mission of it
Manny to the stars Connie Simpson is
sharing 30 years of experience in her
new book The Nanny Connie way I have a
lot of great tips one of which is about
drinking beer when I started to know
that I had a lot of moms that wanted to
breastfeed I had to figure out how to
get moms who weren't producing a lot of
milk or how to get them to produce a lot
of milk and then dark beer came into the
picture and I did it with Brooke Brooke
Shields and we'd sit there and giggle
and she'd pump and eat snacks and have
beer and life was good it's just like
I knew I could produce this much milk I
was like and I keep drinking the beer
it's good nanny Connie has worked with a
who's who of celebrity parents including
Jessica Biel and Justin Timberlake they
were like okay here's how we want it
Justin was serious about having his
sleep in his space and just was serious
about she was having a home birth and I
was sitting there shaking my hand go a
lord have mercy eating or play out in
either way
Jessica ended up delivering baby Silas
in a hospital via emergency c-section
while Papa Timberlake learned a valuable
lesson
Justin learned a month and a half later
that sleeping in his house was not an
option so he came in the kitchen window
day and he said because I said you know
I get it I get it yeah babies just don't
sleep those first five months were
incredibly challenging when it came to
coaching the Clooney's nanny Connie
brought it back to basics I met George
some years ago while through Matt Damon
I knew that I wanted to give them that
opportunity to be parents not to have
people peering into their lives and you
know nitpicking it was really fun to
watch them both be parents and not have
that worry on their shoulder and you
know they had spit up they had crying
babies but they loved it and I loved it
even more talk to me a little bit about
twins you know some of the extra
challenges associated you know I feel
like if you do twins you can do anything
you have to so you play chess you don't
play checkers you're always two steps
ahead of yourself one of many Connie's
key rules it's not all about mom even
celebrity dads need support two dads
have serious needs you know they've been
so supportive for those nine months and
you know they've they've kind of had
their head halfway in the game and not
all the way in there a father's kind of
lost because he doesn't know what to
expect so if you give him a mission like
stock off the changing table you know or
fix my breast feeding area or those kind
of deals where they go well I can help I
feel like I can do something I think one
of the biggest things you taught us and
I think that you know and it goes
certainly for the second baby but the
first ones there is no failure there's
just new solutions yes there was so much
fun she'd come home from the hospital
and was just like okay I'm gonna
breastfeed I kept watching her and
monitoring the situation I go okay it's
coming it's coming
and she woke up that next morning and it
was milk was all in and she was like so
we instantly went into the ice and the
pumping and you know the heat and you
know trying to ward off the mastitis and
the feedings and she looked at me with
those beautiful little eyes going how
does anyone know this I said sweetheart
that's why I'm here for you along with
her book nanny Connie
can be there for you too via an
augmented reality app just point your
device at the book for support in real
time
anyone who's if you want to know what an
angel looks like like in human form
we're all it know
[Music]